dame la présidente ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre de l'Économie des
Finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et numérique monsieur le ministre comme
vous devez le savoir on rassemblement
historique se tient à proximité de
l'Assemblée nationale organisée à
l'initiative des artisans bouchés
charcutiers ils sont venus de la France
entière pour manifester leur désarroi
ces artisans n'ont pourtant pas la
culture de la manifestation cela fait 20
ans que la profession n'a pas manifesté
depuis la crise de lavage folle en effet
il subissent de plein fouet l'explosion
des prix de l'énergie si bien que les 80
000 femmes et hommes du secteur alerte
aujourd'hui sur la gravité de la
situation le gouvernement n'a pas saisi
l'ampleur des difficultés de la
profession les conséquences économiques
et sociales imposées par cette crise
énergétique son dramatique si le
gouvernement ne prend pas ses
responsabilités dans les semaines qui
viennent nous assisterons collectivement
à la mort de nombreuses entreprises les
dispositifs actuels ne répondent la
réalité de terrain 40% des entreprises
se trouvent dans une véritable zone
blanche et ne peuvent bénéficier du
bouclier tarifaire de plus la mesure de
l'amortisseur électrique prévue pour
2023 pour les non éligibles et plus
qu'insuffisante aujourd'hui la
tarification est en hausse de près de
400 %, vos mesures pour la période
d'octobre décembre ne couvriront ainsi
que 20 à 30% de l'augmentation elles
sont donc inadaptées et
inefficaces pour ces artisans les
augmentations du prix de l'électricité
viendrait réduire drastiquement leurs
résultats leur rémunération leur
capacité à rembourser les emprunts qui
plus est dans un contexte où les prix
des matières premières ont augmenté de
12%, sans compter les difficultés de
recrutement au sein de la filière et ce
malgré une revalorisation des salaires
de plus de 7%, c'est une profession à
bout de souffle et en danger qui
manifeste aujourd'hui pouvez-vous donc
monsieur le ministre vous engagez à
prendre des mesures réellement efficaces
pour protéger nos artisans et TPE
maillon fort du lien social notamment en
zone rurale